im sommer 2008 zehn gelangen einem
forschungsteam der nasa etwas
sensationelles den wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern war es gelungen
bakterien direkt an bord der iss der
internationalen raumstation in einem
test zu identifizieren aber außer
krankheiten warten noch mehr große
risiken auf die astronauten und
astronauten im weltall die drei f
dicksten jetzt bei pixum science fiktion
ihr gibt es täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts und haben dank
für euren themenvorschlag auf whatsapp
und herzlich willkommen platz frei die
schwerelosigkeit die menschen sind nun
mal eigentlich nicht für ein leben im
weltall geboren und das zeigt sich schon
an den folgen der schwerelosigkeit für
den menschlichen körper nicht umsonst
müssen astronauten und astronautinnen
nach ihrer reise ins all erst einmal
wieder lernen auf der erde zu laufen
kein wunder denn obwohl jeden tag
krafttraining auf dem programm steht
geht die rückenmuskulatur im all um etwa
20 prozent zurück und das schon nach ein
paar monaten kurios klingt auch erst
einmal dass die hälfte der astronauten
astronauten auf der iss an schmerzen im
bereich der wirbelsäule leidet und das
obwohl der rücken ja entlastet wird und
der rücken ist nicht das einzige das
durch die schwerelosigkeit in
mitleidenschaft gezogen wird denn das
blut im körper verteilt sich und die
flüssigkeitsmenge verringert sich viele
astronauten und astronautin leiden unter
einem blut andrang im kopf wenn der
mechanismus der auf der erde dazu führt
dass das herz gegen die schwerkraft
arbeitet und das blut in den kopf
befördert gerät durch die
schwerelosigkeit im all gehörig
durcheinander
das zeigt sich an angeschwollenen
schleimhäuten die sich nach einer fiesen
erkältung anfühlen deutlich wird das
aber auch noch einmal nach der rückkehr
der teams auf die erde sie können sich
tatsächlich zunächst nur kurz aufrecht
halten denn dann werden gehirn und kommt
zu wenig durchblutet und sie werden und
nicht platz zwei kosmische strahlung auf
platz zwei ist die kosmische strahlung
die man als astronaut oder astronauten
im weltall abbekommt denn kein
raumschiff dieser welt kann diese
gefährliche strahlung so gut abhalten
wie es die atmosphäre die ozonschicht
und das magnetfeld der erde
auf der iss ist das weniger ein problem
weil das erdmagnetfeld einiges davon
bereits weiter außen abhält
marsmissionen die demnächst anstehen
würden aber auch bedeuten dass die
besatzung eine große strahlendosis
abbekommen
und fest steht sie kann das menschliche
gewebe und werfen zellen tatsächlich
schädigen
da sie die aluminiumhülle des
raumschiffes durchdringt medizin teams
befürchten dass die strahlung direkt
auch auswirkungen auf die astronauten
und astronauten haben könnte
beispielsweise könnte die emotionale
stabilität und die reaktionsfähigkeit
die könnten bei den nachlassen aber auch
das krebsrisiko steigt durch die
strahlung forschungsteams weltweit sind
dabei medikamente zu entwickeln die die
wirkung der kosmischen strahlung
abfedern könnten beispielsweise in dem
die menschlichen zellen strahlen
resistenter gemacht werden
platz eins menschliches versagen auch
wenn dieser punkt vielleicht erst einmal
nicht auf der hand liegt landet er doch
auf platz eins das zeigen statistiken
ganz deutlich zwei von fünf
amerikanischen raumfähren waren
abgestürzt und das nur weil die
verantwortlichen bei der nasa dachten
dass die bekannten probleme nicht so
dramatisch sein an schlimmer irrtum
ein weiteres beispiel apollo 13 hier
konnte die besatzung noch gerettet
werden
doch das ist bei mars fliegen ja schon
fast ausgeschlossen denn die erde als
sicherer hafen ist viel zu weit entfernt
menschen machen fehler und wir sind eben
alle nur menschen und wenn er jetzt an
künstliche intelligenz als lösung für
das problem denkt muss ich euch hier
enttäuschen wenn sie jetzt eine ki kann
nicht jede gefährliche situation richtig
einschätzen und angemessen reagieren die
schweige denn abschätzen was die
menschen an bord in zukunft für fehler
machen werden umso wichtiger ist eine
gute arbeitsatmosphäre und ein team das
zusammen funktioniert das hilft auch
dabei eine art lagerkoller an bord
auszuschließen denn das kann man sich
sicher vorstellen im weltall gibt es
keine privatsphäre oder nur eine sehr
geringe noch schlimmer also als im büro
oder betrieb wenn man den ganzen tag auf
seinen arbeitskollegen abhängen muss und
jeder hat so seine gewohnheiten
schmatzen beispielsweise oder aber immer
denselben witze erzählen und anders als
wir es von der erde kennen kann man eben
nicht mal schnell nach draußen gehen und
durchatmen und die reise mit der ice es
ist ja nun auch mal nicht von kurzer
dauer ganz im gegensatz zu einer
möglichen mars-mission mehrere monate
wäre man dann unterwegs und die
astronauten hätten auf dem weg erst
einmal nicht so viel zu tun wir müssen
also auf jeden fall räume geschaffen
werden die zumindest ein wenig
privatsphäre möglich machen denn auch
wenn sich schlägereien in der
schwerelosigkeit eher schwierig
gestalten würden streit herein und
feindseligkeiten einer guten atmosphäre
im weg stehen und dann im schlimmsten
fall auch zu menschlichem versagen
führen
die fundamentale bedeutung der raumfahrt
draufklicken anschauen und natürlich die
neugier zone abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran